we are here with
dr mohammad mahdi
the former professor from the john
hopkins university
and you can read a little bit more about
him at the deanshow.com he has his own
section there and we're continuing on
talking about the verbatim word of god
now in previous episodes we talked about
the compilation of the quran we're going
to talk about some of the miracles of
this quran the verbatim word
of the one who created us the one who
gave us life will give us death who
we're going to have to return back to
the one who's going to judge us and at
the end
if we do everything that he's told us to
do if we live by this quran then we have
the beautiful ward of paradise if we
don't then
you're smart enough to figure out what
is opposite to that so let's talk when
we come back more about the quran you
don't want to go nowhere
maybe it's just to break the ice
assalaamu alaikum
how are you i'm wonderful how about you
alhamdulillah thank you for being with
us again thank you for hosting me
thank you listen we we uh we talked
about and we're continuing to talk about
something that is
a guidance for the whole of mankind the
verbatim war the of the creator the
heavens and earth in arabic we say allah
in previous episodes we talked about the
compilation of the quran in this episode
we want to talk about some of the
miracles but before we go on to that can
you just summarize a little bit about
what we discussed in the previous
episodes about the quran okay
uh the the we said that first of all
allah confirmed in the quran
that he will keep the quran safe
unchanged
and allah fulfilled his promise as he
always does his promise and
alhamdulillah we have the proof now
if you go everywhere in the world
on the mountains of suzuki of japan yeah
or in the valleys of jakarta or if you
go to arizona if you go to any place in
the world if there are people on the
moon it'd be the same thing of course if
there are people there of course there
were some people who were there
yeah and you will find the same
copy of the quran nothing different
nothing different
had there been let me raise this
question for everyone who would really
love to have reflection of mantra had
there been two copies at the time of the
prophet salallahu or even at the time of
the companions they would have been
these two copies nowadays
we don't know any single copy that's
different from the other it's the same
quran that and this is an example that
you can see in mecca when at least half
a million people praying behind the imam
and mecca and if he makes a mistake
everybody
in the masjid would respond to correct
him so that's that just for our
non-muslim audience if the quran is
something that we absolutely recite
during the prayer yes absolutely so if
he makes a mistake somebody from
somebody else is going to correct him
yeah if it is a woman and that's why if
she can make a sign
like that to correct him that means he
made a mistake nobody has authority on
the quran nobody has full control on the
quran in terms of that he can make any
change among the muslims and you can see
that there is nowhere in the world
that you would find somebody is reading
something different
this this is the power as i said that in
the previous time that there are
approximately more than 9 million people
who memorize the quran from cover to
cover and this number is increasing day
after day and i assume that they are
exceeding more than uh 10 million
nowadays everywhere in the world and
every muslim and muslim
memorizes part of the quran because this
is the portion that we use in our daily
prayer
but i'm not talking about those every
muslim memorizes part of it but i'm
talking about those who memorize it from
cover to cover 604 pages
we have at least 10 million people on
the earth who memorize it and that's why
muslims are proud to say
that if
some invention that happens in this
world
that somebody invented a material to
erase all the writings
from the books if we happens that we
open all the books in our life and we
find them blank
all the ink all the printing had been
erased muslim would say that in just
few days
in every village and in every city in
the world the quran can be rewritten as
it was the only book that can be
rewritten as it was is the quran that's
enough right there just to have someone
reflect and say hold on any someone
wants to bring any arguments this is
something that puts everything seriously
there's no other scripture right now
everything that's true no this is the
book and no other constitution no other
thing like that
nothing absolutely
so tell us now what does the creator of
the heavens and earth yeah in arabic we
say allah this is the same god of jesus
abraham everything yeah tell us through
this quran
he says this is a guidance for mankind
absolutely what does this mean what does
he want from us yeah
he said that in our life we face some
issues and some problems and some
situations that we need guidance we
don't know what to do in every situation
we don't know what's right and what's
wrong what to drink what to eat what not
to drink what to not to eat how to do
how to deal with your parents what
rights
do your parents have upon you what
rights your spouse has upon you what
rights do your children have upon you
what rights the ruler or the governor of
your country has upon you everyone how
can you answer this question and you
will find a lot of people are making
some suggestions and some options with
all the investment and all the
investigation and all the research and
they come up with things and they
experiment with that
now we have it ready made divine sent to
us from the quran it it just guides you
to the right thing
from the very beginning in the quran
that you would see that now let me talk
about this little bit
how the quran is different from other
books in the world
whether they are man made written books
or some books that are claimed by the
people who believe in them that they are
divine books you can see the difference
when you see the quran first of all
the quran
is defined by the muslim has is the
summary
of the history of humanity
since the creation of the pen that allah
commanded it to write
until the end of the world
then the day of judgment and the
resurrection and what will happen in in
the future
yes there is no other book in the whole
world that covers this span of time
no other book just compare it with any
other book with all these details that's
going to happen that are going to happen
on the day of judgment and in paradise
and
in hellfire with all these details there
is nothing
is
in comparison with the quran nothing is
comparable to the quran
so now you find and and and this quran
that sums up the history of humanity
is summed up in the beginning chapter
which is called the opening which is
called al-fatiha the opening the mother
of the book it's called the mother of
the book if you don't mind can can you
we're going to give the translation but
can you just take us and recite this in
the arabic can you do that of course go
ahead please okay
m
me
foreign
foreign
same way it was recited then it's
recited today by
your mouth absolutely by my mouth but
every muslim would recite this no muslim
on the earth you go to china if you
don't speak chinese if you're doing the
prayer you can know what you said in
arabic and people saw how beautiful with
the translation we just gave him this is
directing all worship to the creator
such guidance from him absolutely from
the very beginning if i have the time to
elaborate
on this and we can do this until after
the break yeah
that's it we're going to take a break
and we'll be right back with dr mandu on
a deen show
you have to pray as if everything
depends on allah and it does
but you must work
as if
everything depends on you
and it doesn't
that's my point
you see what i'm saying and i don't like
that i don't like us sitting here what
are you waiting for what are we waiting
for right now what are you waiting for
all these people to come to islam what
are we waiting for what are we waiting
for right now when they're going to come
they're going to come along and bring
these people lost upon waffle put in our
hand the ability to do it not do your
job
let me elaborate on this opening chapter
yeah just very limited number of verses
so the beginning of it it says
alhamdulillah
which means all praise is due to
almighty allah that's the creator of the
heavens and earth absolutely creator of
jesus moses abraham the one who created
the sun and the moon yeah that's the god
now this is the one yeah you see this
verse four four words
alhamdulillah
for allah praise is for allah
the
lord
of the worlds
now look at this word four words
you can never ever find any four words
in any language in the world put beside
each other to make this comprehensive
meaning let me elaborate first of all
al hamdu
all praise
is due to almighty allah a person would
say that
you're thanking someone
before you know him
this may raise a question in the minds
of many people
how do you thank someone who doesn't you
don't know him
and this is a very legitimate question
very good logical question
and the answer is
if you reflect
upon what is around you and what's in
you and you see the heavens you see the
skies and you see the trees and you see
the rivers and you see the mountains and
you see the milky way and you see the
planets and you see the galaxies and you
see all this
you immediately say that there is a
creator
when you look into yourself the organs
in yourself the hands that move
the eyes that see the ears that listen
the heart that moves the 3 trillion
living cells in your body
you would immediately say there's a
creator and you need to thank him for
all these blessings for the water you
drink
for the oxygen that you inhale
for everything that you have for the
eyes that help you see what's around you
and for everything immediately you
realize that there is a creator and the
first thing that you need to know you
need to thank him
for everything that you have because
without him how can you enjoy this life
how can even you exist in this life
without him
so that's why the first word is
alhamdulillah and you
cannot imagine the comfort that comes to
the heart of a human being who believes
in that when he says alhamdulillah
that's why even you find muslims when
they confront calamities and disasters
and crises in this world and when you
ask them how are you they would say
alhamdulillah
even he had lost his job had lost his
house his farm was burned anything any
calamity any situation he would say
alhamdulillah and as in some cultures
they say it it could have been worse
yeah because they know that so now he
deserves and who is he
allah they said alhamdulillah all praise
is due to almighty allah and the word
allah is so unique it's first it's the
proper noun the proper name of almighty
allah his name my name is
your name is eddie his name is hasan
asiri and his name the lord the name of
the lord is allah
and this word allah
includes
all the
attributes of almighty allah the 99
names and beautiful names and attributes
of allah are embedded in this way
so you can imagine how comprehensive
this
the
merciful the most merciful the most
compassionate the all-knowing the
all-hearing the all-wise the most wide
and with all these are embedded in the
word allah you can see how comprehensive
the meaning is
and then
what is the definition of this is now
one name of allah the other
attribute that's mentioned here name he
is
he is the lord of the world
he is the lord of the muslims he is the
lord of the christians he is the lord of
the jews he is the lord of the hindus he
is the lord of all human he is the lord
of
all animals he's the lord of all planets
he's the lord of the oxygen he's the
lord of the rivers he's the lord of the
trees
he's the lord of everything
and now when you say this
that he's the lord of all the world's
the world of humans the world of energy
the world of atom the world of
everything he is the lord of all that
there's an impact on your heart
immediately you would say
this is the one
that i have been looking for
is not the lord of the hindus is not the
lord of the christians it's not just the
lord of the muslims he is the lord of
all the world
there is nothing
greater than them
and this is become so beautiful when you
hear the word allahu akbar
god is greater and you see from this
linguistic comparative it's called
comparative degree
is greater
and the sentence seems that it's not
complete but it is complete is greater
than anything else that you can find
anything that you can anything you can
imagine he's greater than all of this
he's greater than all right that's why
allah is greater
and some people would even translate it
is the greatest but we love to read
because it's in arabic it's comparative
it says that allah is greater greater
than anything that you may think of so
is it out of his love and mercy that he
sent this absolutely as a guidance
absolutely and even after the the
the
opening of the book the first chapter
defines the book
that this is a book of guidance
but before it says it the book of
guidance it has another statement before
this it says that this book there is no
doubt in it there is no error in it
there is no flaw in it there is no
mistake in it there is no skepticism in
it from the very beginning it tells you
before you read yeah and by the way
these words in the beginning which is
there are five words in arabic
yeah then this book there's no doubt in
it
if you compare it
with
the books in the world with the 35
million books and items that are on the
shelves of the library of congress
you would find nothing similar to this
nobody
dares to say that his book has no error
in it or no doubt and no one usually the
author is doing the opposite forgive me
if i made a mistake here absolutely yeah
and they say that this to the best of my
ability and as authors and as writers
know that
the first thing that
you fear that once you finish writing
the book and it is printed
you start being showered by phone calls
and by emails and and people finding
some comments and some flows and some
mistakes
in your writing you say that i wish i
couldn't have written it's too late now
it's on the show it's too late yeah
so even
i know of a person himself in the
virginia area that who became a muslim
because of these words
that this book has no doubt in it
he said
immediately
this book should be the book of the
creator
and his friends asked him it's
too quick and too hasty to make this
quest to make this conclusion
and he said no
i have read approximately 200 books some
of them are called divine books and some
of them are man-made books and he said
that i've never found somebody
saying in his book that his book has no
doubt or no skepticism in it that's
profound that can only be from the
creator if somebody he said this is
exactly his words he said if somebody
dares to say that his book has no flaw
and it has no skepticism and it has no
doubt and it has no mistake in it should
be only the creator and this way
alhamdulillah he became a muslim and
this is another sign that this book is
guidance for people you see the effect
of these words
just five words
and what's more
more striking
allah
himself called
these verses in the quran call them ayat
ayat in arabic means
proof
and evidence
that means that every ayah every verse
every one or two three words together in
the quran that composes a verse
is a sign
is a proof that it is from god and it's
not from someone else that's what it
actually means in arabic exactly
evidence proof and evidence this is the
meaning of the word ayah that's why
allah called these verses proofs
that means proofs from almighty allah
and as i told you earlier that allah
asked people to challenge the quran
just allah has not challenged him but
allah is guiding people
is guiding people to think
and reflect upon the quran can we make
something similar to it if you can so
it's no longer the quran
we will believe in the book that you are
going to write if you challenge the
quran and the arabs
willingly accepted the challenge and
they started writing
thinking and you know that the arts were
the best speakers the perfectionist of
their language they could instead of
talking pros they can talk poetry they
were masters of the language we've never
ever known any other nation that
perfected the languages like the arabs
there are hundreds and tens of examples
and there's not the time to talk about
it they accepted the challenge and they
started making research and making
thinking and writing something
similar and they started bringing it to
consult each other how do you say this
and we started laughing each at each
other
how do you dare
saying that and the quran is seeing it
in that perfect one
and even to the effect that some arabs
were
were afraid to be affected by the quran
so some of them when they visited the
prophet salla and they wanted to observe
them
to monitor them they used to put
something in their ears to plug their
ears to prevent themselves from
listening to the quran
and one of the leaders said that okay
let me test this i will take this i'm a
leader of my tribe
why i'm behaving like a child so he gave
himself the opportunity to listen to the
quran
and immediately the effect appeared on
him
when he went back to his tribe the
people saw him from distance and they
said look at him he came with a
different face
this was the effect of the quran on him
because he understood the language and
he had seen and tested how beautiful the
language of the quran was
we're going to cut out and take a break
and we'll be right back with more of
this miraculous book the quran i just
want to say very simple message
one of the beautiful things about our
religion of islam is the emphasis
on direct ritual and prayer through god
directly there is no intermediary the
lights will go on after the party and
the party will end
it's very simple and very clear there
are no superstitious rituals no strange
incantations the time is running out we
might not make it till tomorrow
and this is something that we need to
think about
dr madhu can you continue elaborating on
the opening chapter of the verbatim word
of god
okay
and
i'm gonna do that but before that i just
want to go back to the first verse in
the chapter in surat al-baqarah that i
was talking about
that allah after comforting the hearts
of the people
that this book has no doubt and it had
no skepticism in it and no
no error in it no flaw in it
allah defined the book
what type of book is the quran
it's guidance
for those who believe in it and in
another verse he said that it's guidance
for mankind and inshallah in one of the
coming episodes i will elaborate and
give examples that how the quran is
addressing all human beings it's not
just for the muslims this important
point you just said that it is a
guidance for the people there's a
criteria here of course the great thing
first of all in another verse it says
that it's guidance for all human beings
yeah
so if you are if you belong to any other
religion if you belong to any other
ideology and you are seeking guidance
what is the answer for this problem you
go to the quran and you will find the
answer there and this is how most of the
people by the way became muslims
most of them they have something in
common they would say that we found the
answer in that book but you have to want
it is that a criteria like if i'm you're
talking about a beautiful car and i'm
not in the market so you have to be in
the market for wanting to be guided by
the one who created you you have to want
it
of course you should first of all you
should be sincere sincere humble and
sincere and looking for the truth yeah
sincere and unbiased and allah said this
in the quran
if you are sincere in looking for the
truth we will def i will definitely
guide you but if you've got too many if
you're pre-occupying if you are you're
not even thinking about money the dollar
that's all that's on or if you are just
reading the quran to find some mistakes
and from this perspective
you will not be guided yeah yeah
you you need to be sincere that you are
looking for the truth
and if you have this condition if you
have this state of the heart in you you
will be guided open mind over here
open-hearted neutral unbiased
read
think
reflect reflect plunder and you will
find that guidance is coming to you
and that's why most of the people who
are guided to islam they will say that
when we read the quran we found the
answers to many things that even by the
way
the people who when they listen to the
quran
and they don't know that this is the
word of allah you would find that they
are affected by this tell us let me
interject because some people have a
missed notion they think okay that we're
guided now and some people they feel
like some spirit is going to come in you
and you'll be start talking in some
foreign tongues and that what are we
talking about when we say guidance
elaborate
i think a very good question i think one
would say that the guy did it you're
looking for the answer for a question
you don't have the answer what should i
do in this situation what should they do
how would i use the money how would i
use the organs
that i have in my body logical just it's
very logical yeah what is the best way
to use my ears
what should i listen to
should i listen to this or this or this
what's your
how to use my eyes in the correct way
how to use my time in the correct how
even to use the money that i have
because a lot of people think that
really this is their money it's
something we muslims believe that allah
entrusted us with this money allah was
the cause that for this you to be rich
yes you did some part of the work
you exerted an effort but allah is the
one who really
caused you for example look at someone
who's like bill gates for example yeah
one of the richest if not the richest
person in the world yeah
had education been the cause for him to
be rich he wouldn't have been rich he
left the university he didn't complete
his
bsc or his master
he was of course a student learning from
all his professors and after just few
years
he hired his professors to work with him
and he did not complete his education he
did not finish his education his degree
and but he's the richest person in the
world
is it because is he the smartest person
in the world i doubt that
but it is the will of allah that made
him and not somebody else rich allah is
observing bill gates and observing them
during observing eddie and observing
everyone
how
you are going to use this money are you
going to use it in the way that pleases
almighty allah the most beneficial way
that to help
people in the world or are you going to
misuse it and abuse the money
and use it in in bad things
so this is the quran
greets you and when i answering these
questions it opens up your heart day
after day that you are looking for the
truth oh now i knew i know the right way
and we can talk about hundreds of
examples in this
again and again and this is my tip and
my advice to everybody to the viewers
and to the listeners
just to take your time and open your
heart
read the quran don't read all of it i
don't advise you at all just read one
chapter just read the first part of it
the second and see and compare it with
other books and you see you would
immediately see the difference once you
see the difference you would know that
this is the book the only book that was
safe kept safe from almighty allah and
it is guidance for people if you are
sincere
in seeking god we look forward god we
want to have you back thank you thank
and thank you for tuning in to another
episode of the dean show come back here
every week where we
try to clear up some of the
misconceptions we've been talking about
the quran if you didn't see parts one
and two with
the dr sheikh
mohammed mahdi you can go to
deanshow.com
and in this episode we talked about the
some of the miraculous nature of the
quran it's a guidance
not just for the muslim but for the
non-muslim for all of mankind and the
teacher just like moses jesus
these messengers that were sent by the
creator of the heavens and earth with
the last and final message of the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him
they were all teachers and he was the
one
that
was showing us how to live the quran
so to learn more
make sure to come back here every week
visit us at the dean show until next
time
peace be unto you
you have to pray as if everything
depends on allah and it does
but you must work
as if
everything depends on you
and it doesn't
that's my point
you see what i'm saying and i don't like
that i don't like us sitting here what
are you waiting for what are we waiting
for right now what are you waiting for
all these people to come to isla what
are we waiting for what are we waiting
for right now when they're going to come
they're going to come along and bring
these people lost upon a waffle put in
our hand the ability to do it now do
your job
it's cold it's late
sleeping
i
arise and ask a lot to think in may
oh allah you see
oh
you know
all the sins i do
i turn to you to forgive my sins and my
heart
i'm your sinful slave
me